[Music]
Enoch love Zoo is a surgeon in a
hospital in Malawi he works long and
hard to help the hundred-plus
patients in his care he often has to
improvise because medication and
instruments are in short supply Malawi
is one of the world's poorest countries
the city of Samba south of capital along
way has a relatively well-equipped
hospital doctor looked sue and his team
received aid from Germany but they still
can't always give their patients the
care they need
[Music]
unless your son Edwin etre para is
pregnant and dr. Lutz ooh and his
assistant are concerned she has a tumor
on one leg and needs surgery
yeah the risk is the Preakness will go
with surgery
so what can you do
we need to know what it is we did the
excision last last year this is a
recurrent tumor unfortunately they were
not able to pay for the histology so it
didn't matter what we're dealing with
looks like a sarcoma so we need the
history once we have confirmation is
cancer the best I think is to amputate
my leg communicating bad news to
patients is an all too frequent part of
dr. Lutz's routine he makes the rounds
of the wards twice a week he and his
assistant devotes special attention to
the more difficult cases every patient
they're able to release is another
success such as this woman who came in
with ulcerated abdominal muscles another
patient has just been admitted with a
suspected rectal tumor what kind of
problem do you have I have blood in my
stool when did that start
it started when I had the baby the
history is she gave birth in March we
were there any changes in bowel habits
prior to passing stool not before I was
pregnant do your intestines make any
noise before a bowel movement I had
diarrhea and sometimes constipation what
did you Mark how often do you have these
problems quite often is this your only
illness there's nothing else he also
asks about her HIV status which is
negative
dr. Lutz ooh never manages to see all
his patients in one day and the ward is
almost always overcrowded but he still
takes time for every case he can three
procedures are scheduled for the
operating room the next morning that
might easily involve three improvised
solutions if the required equipment is
missing the first patient is barely
three months old she has hydrocephaly a
genetic defect that occurs relatively
frequently in Malawi and involves an
accumulation of fluid in the brain the
assistants have all had basic medical
training and continue to learn on the
job the more experienced among them can
even operate on their own an operation
won't help this defect a tube will have
to be run from the brain case down to
the abdominal cavity that will drain the
fluid off straight into the abdominal
cavity and take the pressure off the
baby's head testing the children Caesar
have analysis not on a dissecting
that's it you only have this one okay do
you have a big plumber nice let's just
go to yours right
Caesar so we have just improvise
something this time all that was missing
were the right size scissors they
proceed yo into where we are happy so
you we have which one of with the
attendees okay now the next is this one
listen and we take the bow suction as
the only surgeon here dr. Lutz ooh
shoulders a lot of responsibility he
teaches the assistants as much as he can
there are precious few fully qualified
doctors here yeah mainly what we need is
more an aphasia because the anesthetist
i shortened number so we don't read over
it to the full capacity of this theatre
dr. Lutz ooh is confronted with
shortages of equipment and medicine on a
daily basis as you want to do your job
you always want to have something that
you need to do the job in handy but
sometimes it's so difficult you don't
have this I don't of that but sometimes
it's frustrating pay obviously slow very
low so it's also frustrating he earns
the equivalent of around 450 euros a
month an extremely low wage for a
qualified surgeon at lunchtime dr. Lu
Zhu has to pick his daughter up from
daycare before returning to the clinic
it's the only break he gets from the
hospital routine dr. Lu Zhu is the first
surgeon to complete his studies and
training entirely in Malawi
and he's the only consultant surgeon at
the Zumba Central Hospital
my interest was to be an engineer
but then they've just changed when
sometime around the same video yeah my
father's to have this book bought modern
ways to health that was me driving so I
just took it and started reading it so
the story's out see about cider II put
my attention when I got very interested
I said ah this is how you really can
help
yeah in 2016 at age 37 dr. Lutzer moved
his family to Zomba as a state employee
he had to go where he was assigned he
hopes to work in the capital a long way
someday although he likes his work here
Sambas hospital is one of the few
central state clinics in Malawi it
serves a population of nearly 4 million
people the most complicated cases are
sent here there is no charge for
treatment the lines outside the
admissions office just keep growing
while the nurses try to assign the
patients according to urgency there's
still no casualty Department an average
of 15 patients are admitted here every
day the mortality rate at the hospital
is high close to 20 percent for some of
the wards it's never easy for an igloo
zoo to take when nothing can be done to
help the patients sometimes the problems
are beyond you for example somebody
needs blood there is no blood has a
niche bureau for what dude lays in match
again rubbish so sometimes the system
fails you sometimes maybe you can do
something the way you can do something
that's where we try as much as possible
we perform new hospital facilities or
extension buildings are financed almost
exclusively by nongovernmental
organizations a small casualty
Department is finally being built with
funding from the samba hospital project
in Germany the Association has been
supporting the clinic for the last 15
years its chairman olaf ba does what he
can to help dr. Lu su the typical
history of - say by illness you think
it's malaria sometimes the mayor may be
positive sometimes not you treat malaria
you don't improve then you
of abdominal pains which gets worsened
with typical title the two men work
together to try to increase the quality
of care in the surgery unit Olaf Bach
comes to Zomba twice a year for six
weeks at a time and oversees the
transport of obsolete medical equipment
from Germany German doctors and students
also come to help with the hospital
Olaf Bach is head surgeon at the
university clinic in llena it's fine
bringing it I think it's okay here and I
just opened a little bit down here and
she should go for dressing tomorrow
that's good enough
tell me Danny good bus that's good
that's good enough alright move the
fingers ah cranberry won't be any hmm
it's been around 20 years since boss
first came to Malawi as a young doctor
back then he also worked for a time here
in Samba I would not be the person I am
without Malawi I became shaped as a
doctor as a surgeon here I founded my
academic career by malaria research here
so I would not be in the position I am
in Germany now financially and
professionally without so I own
something to discuss they helped us a
lot in terms of equipment and other
materials which we usually lack and they
also transferring skills to
which is very good and
I think we are benefiting a lot from
this cooperation and with it continuous
an igloo Tzu is aware of how much he and
his clinic in Samba need the aid from
abroad like his commitment its
indispensable to providing the patients
here the care they need and ensuring
they receive treatment with dignity
[Music]